[Musique]
savoir quand je vois l'appeler maman
jorien par les enchères du risque au
quotidien avec énormément de décision
est-ce que tu as le nom de cet enfant là
c'est pas des décisions c'est la vie
d'enfants hockey est ce qu on sait la
force qu'elle a utilisé ce qu'avait
démarque pas une marque c'est sûr quand
on arrive sur 1,5 comme ça on n'a pas le
temps de réfléchir à ce que parce qu'on
a après l'université on agit comment ça
a été deux semaines donc chalet de ta
propre canapa château
ces autres qui te l'ont donné ta famille
de matisse a présentement inquiète
beaucoup de 5 ha ok de cette inquiétude
c'est bon je le bien nommé pas un
[Musique]
à 8 heures à 10 ans oui en tout cas au
niveau des frustrations de claquages de
porte des coups dans le mur c'est de la
violence avec des gens qui sont très
explosif actions mon arrivée mais
d'autres supports comme on voit
communément mais ça serait sûrement
brisé c'est sûr que c'est beau idée
assez pour un milieu familial mais cinq
minutes ce qui très sécuritaire a chargé
des interventions que les états monarchy
qui travaillent s'agit de viol mais
c'est pour la veille enfin est-ce que ta
mine et à 12 mois ferme et l'autre
robinet mais si souvenez affirmé aby
toile comme faux
[Musique]
faut lui rappeler la retraite en général
il faut lui il faut s'assurer aussi même
si la colère cette route sun la fausse
assuré que soit pas en train de faire
d'autres choses que ce trou de signaux
qu'ils soient pas en train de de faire
un mauvais coup de mou y est son linge
de mettre de l'eau un peu partout des
choses comme ça mais c'est à toi sur ton
lit pour le faire séquences choisies
comme jeu pour essayer de bouger les
gens le but principal c'est que soit on
arrive au niveau de fonctionnalité
normal
normal je dirais normal mais le normal
est très très larges zones qu'ils soient
fonctionnaires et que soit en mesure
d'aller à l'école de développer des
relations de se développer lui-même par
personne et puis d'être en sécurité
là-bas la base on vise la barre puis en
ratant charmant mais c'est un jeune qui
a besoin d'une supervision constat
roquettes
quel genre de famille d'accueil puis
sophie pedder
non moi je reste confiant qu'on va
trouver est ce que j c qui ont un jour
on va essayer de sortir un jour un jour
menacé de sortir au travail en classe je
suis vraiment fier de toi
très bien une éducation mais semble le
mieux super journée
yes he à vous faire sourire le sait
marquer brise une pelle qu'il trouve pas
ces petits points
bien en place au départ on avait un
paquet qui fait de la violence à la
maison toute l'union veut retirer le
père du milieu
mais s'il souhaitait probablement que
les méthodes éducatives super parce que
c'est moi le mot mood cessé de lui qui
sortait lundi
j'ai l'impression qu'ils avaient pas le
droit de pleurer j'ai l'impression que
tic soin des bébés beaucoup parce que
c'est lui qui le nomme l'aï dit c'est
mon père tout le monde quand je pleurais
non pas que le géant pendant ces drôles
c'est lui qui va nous dire un mot faut
que j'améliore mon langage ou j'améliore
ma violente
je fais la violence et ils nous disent
oh il y en a eu les études d'audience
d'ailleurs en fonctionnement dimanche
matin il ya eu il y voir un état dirigé
avec jusqu'à tri ace management
il ajoute qu'elle jaune
là dessus
pourquoi
petit couac à damas
ouais j'ai hâte aussi jointe la monnaie
tu l'as vu ce qu'ils retournent chez eux
puis sept amarrés à sauter de toit de
votre nez chez toi ça te fait pas oui ok
c'est normal c'est quoi qui inquiète
regarde moi on travaille en simple pour
que je retourne chez toi et ton pour
avoir des contacts avec ma main puis on
va travailler avec ma maladie
alone éducatrice travail est amer vous
savez il ya une travailleuse sociale
travaille elle aussi peut-on parler des
gens aussi éclater tout le monde
travaille fort du travail des objectifs
forts un temps amélioré beaucoup de
politesse beaucoup aussi le respect de
l'intervention avec les filles c'était
difficile
belle avec maman ça va être pareil
autrement dit faire quand on est chez
elle c'est qu'il faut maîtriser un qui
va faire les interventions esthétiques
vous décidez les règles la routine moins
de garçons à jamais